hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Ryan Wright and my name is Jerry so
today my neighbors are being dicks once
more and playing their music so loud I
would ask them to turn it down but I
accidentally threw up on their car so I
don't wanna [ __ ] with him anymore but
I'm excited for today's video
Terminator Genisys the official second
trailer boy I'm really looking forward
to this I like the production company
that's taking over the franchise
Annapurna yeah although they've changed
their involvement slightly so Megan
Ellison who is like the head of
Annapurna is still like the executive
producer so it's kind of them it's just
like their names not on it so I don't
know what that means but Annapurna like
is the reason right now I want to see
this because the previous trailers have
always left me like with this weird
middle ground feeling of like that looks
cool this looks weird
that looks cool though but this looks
weird I like what they're doing with it
I like the little Star Trek time-travel
fit they got going on a kind of [ __ ]
with the you know the linear timeline of
things yeah what I mean time travel has
always been an integral part of
terminator yeah but never this specific
where it's like because before it's just
like oh this machine's from the future
now it's like no it's changing the
present for sure you know like really
well you know it's more than just
preventing the war borrowing like
salvation it's like we've we've usually
had Terminator sent back to present we
haven't been like [ __ ] we're in the
future but we gotta go back yeah exactly
I know the whole goal is prevent
Judgment Day which they suck at doing
like you know he's never do it well if
the movie was it should have ended at
Terminator 2 now it's not anodite
Terminator 2 so I don't know what the
final goal is well that's the really
hard thing is like the further these
movies go there's like that ultimate
question of like well why don't you just
go back so far yeah like you could
easily trace the lineage of like where
of Skynet like who created this and who
did that like you could probably you
just go back further than Sarah Connor
there's no but I do hearts just kill the
baby whoo Creed it's my impression of
miles Dyson he's in a shock yeah he does
that like several time
well he does get anxiety yeah shooting
Blasi speakers and now we're probably
gonna have like a whole discussion of
the cow it's about time Jeff John you
can do this you just go and you don't
look back there is a Targaryen whoa
my whole life I prepared my son to lead
humanity in the fight against the
machines
[Music]
there was one thing I could never
prepare him for machines tried to rig
the game send a terminator back to the
time before the ward to kill my mother
I'll go back let me save her I don't
know I don't like Hollywood really wants
us to like check oh [ __ ]
[Music]
you know one prepping for you to arrive
over a decade we would Terminator it is
nice to meet you I've been trying to
teach him to blend oh what have they
done to my son
survival's what you taught me
[Music]
it's not machine
not man
I can't leave it whatever they did they
don't need a rehearsal
everything's changed
hell yeah
I've been waiting for you
Sooey
[Music]
gotta get him off me
I'll be back what
[Music]
I love it
I'm sorry I don't know you feel I love
it that looks awesome
I love parts of it every trailer I see
for this movie makes it feel uneven to
me the one thing I didn't like I didn't
okay I know that chicks in Game of
Thrones and everyone loves her but I
wasn't a fan of her at least the
delivery of what I was hearing her do it
did not seem that great Jai Courtney
don't know why Hollywood really wants us
to love the [ __ ] I don't really care for
Jai cornu for some reason I actually
don't mind I corny but most people I
hear talk about her like I just don't
like this guy but he gets so much more
he does get a lot of work like the
really trying is such high profile
things first off okay I was like alright
cool cuckoo that was funny with Arnold
when you see by a smile yeah that was
great
I hope there's more that kind of humor
in this film right when John Connor
showed up at the hospital she's like
John I was like oh interesting and then
you find out that they've like done
something to him to make him like the
t1000 and you're like even more
interesting that's a cool yeah see
that's the thing is like every single
trailer for this movie always has things
from like that's super cool oh I don't
know sure I hope the story merits this
but just on the surface level which is
what the trailer is I'm a little kind of
worried because it's almost like a
Greatest Hits medley of everything that
was good about any Terminator film it's
like up brought back the t1000 this guy
kind of looks like an Asian Robert
Patrick alright now we're back in the
present with old Arnold and Sarah Connor
alright and now we're gonna sing how
Reese back again because that's familiar
and then you know oh here's some cool
shots of the war see I like that though
I do too it could really work this is
just because I've seen so many reboots
and sequels and stuff happen where they
bring back all that [ __ ] we liked it's
like Sin City to bug me because it was
like here's all that [ __ ] you liked but
it didn't feel the same because it fell
a shoehorn in but like you said there's
there's individual things in all the
Terminator films and they're taking all
of that and kind
throwing it into one now and that's what
I think is really cool about it honestly
you got like a little glimpse of Arnold
fighting young Arnold it looks like it's
better than what we saw in Salvation
with Christian Bale and Arnold probably
because Arnold's actually involved in
that and another thing that I find
interesting is I'm actually drawn and
this is to me is a big deal I'm really
drawn to the whole story and Arnold is a
plus it's not like I just want to
[ __ ] see more Arnold you know yeah
yeah I'm drawn to the entire thing I
remember watching rise of the machines
because that came out many years after
part two because part two should have
ended it part 3 comes out and I remember
going like I like this film mainly
because I still enjoy watching Arnold
yeah this one I'm really drawn to the
grand scope of things it's not about
focusing on Arnold and see how I felt
about salvation when I saw the trick and
Arnold wasn't even in the trailer I was
like ooh like ah this is cool even
though there's no Arnold this still
looks rad I'm so excited and that I
think had a better trailer than this one
I'm not saying it's gonna be bad I'm
worried but the salvation trailer was
kind of manipulative they got a great
song and then they just put a bunch of
images over the great song that's mainly
how that trailer worked true this one is
showing you a lot of scenes rather than
like let's just put a song here and then
just show a montage of awesome clips
well it's a lot of action this is just a
[ __ ] yeah I mean eventually that's
all trailers aren't I mean this is this
pretty close to the trailer I saw a few
days ago except they added all the John
Connor stuff which is cool like that's
that's a whole new thing so I glad
they've got you know I love that change
with making John Connor an enemy now but
that they have to save when we don't
know the circumstances so there could be
even more to that like I think it's
definitely got potential I just like
John Connor could have volunteered to do
it you know or maybe it's a robot in its
line yeah it's just the t1000 a daughter
a little bit or maybe you know Skynet
created a new robot and modeled it on
John Connor and like holy [ __ ] yeah ok
but what I love is this trailer is
making it feel a little bit more fresh
again for me it's making me ask
questions like I want to know the
answers to these things I can't go the
rest of my life without knowing what's
going on I'm like I have to like now
what's going on well guys I made sure do
using a new rating system today oh [ __ ]
in honor of 100k subs I'm gonna probably
this right now I guess we'll go with I
will watch it in the theaters I will
wait for it on DVD I don't care to watch
it I will watch this into theaters
[Music]
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
right Jerry has a playlist on this
channel right reasons to Jerry's right
and you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
right because all the words make us look
better with the ladies even though we're
both taken mm-hmm taken three or
virginity's we're taking listen to
Lindsay the YouTube channel person
members remember listen to Lindsay do I
wanted to give her a shout-out we've
been talking every once in a while on
Instagram she's really into me and I'm
like dude back off I'm so in love with
my girlfriend and we had the best sex
ever don't [ __ ] with me and Lindsay's
constantly persisting but I admire her
ambition so I wanted to give her a
shout-out right now because do you you
know if you have a philosophy that
persistence wears down resistance I
don't believe that works for everything
but if you believe it's gonna work it's
cool that you're at least honoring your
own point of view but just know
nothing's gonna happen with us it's a
really special shadow